let's stick with the phones we're going
next to our caller from the 6-5 one area
code caller from 651 tell us your name
where you're calling from and what your
question is today
well first off how's it going David my
name is Cody and I am calling out of the
st. Paul area great speak up as much as
you can Cody and what's on your mind
today
hold on let's let's before we go any
further Cody are we do you have us on
speakerphone right now
you don't okay all right we can barely
hear you but go ahead okay my question
kind of crawls around cryptocurrency and
the impact that it could potentially
have on the sanctions moving forward so
I guess my question is more on your
thoughts on how that's really going to
affect things and moving forward with
the readily prevalent availability of
cryptocurrency moving forward yeah
so it's going to depend on how much pick
up cryptocurrency has and how much money
flows into it so right now I don't
believe that there's really a way to
significantly circumvent sanctions
merely through cryptocurrency
however if I see a lot of money move in
the direction of cryptocurrency it could
be possible my concern with
cryptocurrency and I've been dollar-cost
averaging into the big three crypto
currencies for a little while now is
that there's a big bubble going on in
cryptocurrency and in fact I've been
reading the third iteration of
Schiller's irrational exuberance which
came out I think it was a few months ago
I don't know exactly and there are many
elements of what's going on in Bitcoin
particularly but in cryptocurrency more
broadly that signals that would be a
major bubble so I think that that's a
more present concern than the
circumvention of sanctions right now
okay well awesome yeah I mean that's
kind of what I was coming to ISM the
more that you kind of read up on it the
more that it seems likely that the
bubble will eventually it seems like
kind of pop on that and I just didn't
know if that would happen before it
would really affect the sanction
abilities
so I guess that's where I was just kind
of going yeah I don't know the answer to
that and I think anyone who tells you
that they do is merely guessing so I
don't I don't I just don't think we're
gonna know the answer to that until
until we know it for sure
all right correct better from you always
good to hear from our fans in Minnesota
thanks very much for the call
absolutely take care all right